en busca de la revancha por la Casa
Blanca Donald Trump invitó a cientos de
Seguidores a su club de Florida para lo
que denominó un gran anuncio
para hacer que Estados Unidos sea grande
y glorioso de nuevo esta noche anunció
mi candidatura a la presidencia de
Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
durante algo más de una hora en un
discurso farragoso Trump habló de su
historial económico prometiendo llevar a
la inflación a cero y retrató a un país
sumido en la oscuridad debido a la
administración vaiden
en lugar de poner a Estados Unidos en
último lugar como ha hecho la
administración biden muy abiertamente y
con valentía porque no me imagino
diciendo pongamos a Estados Unidos en
último lugar creo que hace falta valor
volveremos a poner a Estados Unidos en
primer lugar
en la Cumbre del g20 en Indonesia baiden
dijo que no tenía realmente una
respuesta a la propuesta de Trump pero
en Twitter el presidente de Estados
Unidos dijo que siente que su predecesor
Le falló hasta Estados Unidos con un
vídeo en el que dice que Trump atacó los
derechos básicos favoreció la economía
para los ricos y mimó a los extremistas
dos veces sometido a un juicio político
Trump se enfrenta actualmente a
múltiples demandas e investigaciones
problemas ilegales que no han acabado
con sus esperanzas para 2024
pero tal y como prometió en 2016 soy su
voz Yo soy su voz el establishment de
Washington quiere silenciarnos pero no
se lo permitiremos
justo antes de su discurso los asesores
de Trump presentaron los documentos
oficiales para su candidatura su anuncio
relativamente temprano se produce
mientras intenta posicionarse por
delante de otros aspirantes republicanos
en concreto del gobernador de Florida
ron de santis el ex presidente Aún es
muy popular entre la base del partido
pero el pobre desempeño de los
republicanos en las elecciones de medio
término especialmente de los candidatos
respaldados por Trump deja a los
conservadores preocupados
[Música]